countdown is on to kick off and no one
wants to miss the moment
I'm very happy Ghana is among seven
African teams playing in Qatar 2022 I'm
a big time football fan and I will not
miss any of the matches that is why I
have brought my TV to be repaired so I
can comfortably watch all the matches
I'm confident the black stars will bring
the cup home if they don't play a good
game surely they will be part of the
finals
there is a definite Trend here repair
chefs are seeing an increase in all
television sets being brought in
it's no coincidence
with the football time coming many
people few people are bringing in their
activities for repairs since they cannot
offer go for the new ones they are
bringing their televisions and we're
fixing for them ghanaians hope the
national team the black stairs will make
it to the semis this time around a very
ambitious dream as no other African
country has ever reached that stage but
whether or not they get there the
football World Cup will be a welcome
Destruction for both government and
citizens from the painful economic
crisis they are going through at the
moment
a lesson is a self-described football
fanatic he Scouts for Talent on the
pitch and off the page he too is living
nothing to Charles I'm not missing any
match at all I'm well prepared my DStv
subscription has been paid you know I
have a few friends come in we have some
drinks in the fridge it's going to be
really great then again the power supply
in Ghana is like the British weather you
can't trust it so I have my generator
serviced ready for action the moment the
power goes off generator kissing
the excitement is palpable alasan says
the football month will be good for
everyone so it's going to it's going to
bring a lot
to a lot of people in the world not only
in Ghana the whole world is going to be
calm for at least one for one month and
then after the football we see what next
for now what's next is making sure all
these work before the first kick on
November 20th Ahmad Idris Al Jazeera
Accra